angela merkels zehn heiße hat sich noch
frühstück das hat noch geklappt weil ich
frage warum gebauten hotels in unser
flug von leipzig nach köln es
ausgefallen deswegen mussten mit der
bahn fahren unser flug von leipzig nach
köln ist irgendwie ausgefallen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt mit dem zug
fahren will man von leipzig nach köln
mit der bahn fahren will fährt die bahn
hat zwangsläufig über frankfurt und da
wir uns gedacht der pendler nach
frankfurt
und da hinten ist sogar die skyline auch
voll nett das hotel hat uns dann gestern
abend gegen noch so rotwein gebracht und
oliven und zur cracker und käse und so
aber ich hasse oliven cracker und käse
also danke für die aufmerksamkeit aber
wir hassen dass das cool und ich
zwischen den man mal so eine teils aus
dem fenster macht
das langweilig halter des halters unser
hotel in frankfurt ein purer hass der
relativ weit oben in dem gebäude bringen
verboten
[Musik]
ich habe auf dem klo sitzen die haare 5
jetzt allerdings erst mal auf das thema
dieses videos zu sprechen zu kommen
meine damen und herren wir machen heute
einen hottest also wir schauen wie heißt
wir sind ich auch früher schon mal
einige videos auf dieser website gemacht
und auf dieser website kann man halt
einfach bilder hochladen von
beispielsweise einen selbst oder von
irgendwelchen personen die man im
internet findet und dann sagt er mich
sobald die heisman geschätzt wird auf
irgendwas gala von nod hort des
beautiful oder irgendwie sogar ich dafür
allerdings einen pc braucht und gerade
keinen pc dabei habe und wir auch noch
in frankfurt sind werden wir jetzt
erstmal die stadt gehen wir werden
irgendwie im café gehen ein bisschen
shoppen und das wetter fakt halt hart ab
weil das ist von reglern und ich muss
erst mal noch ein bisschen schön weil
die nummer packen muss
wir laufen durch frankfurt und das
wetter hat sich tatsächlich war noch
nicht gewässert jeder irgendwie ein
schirm aus dem euro-schutzschirm
gerutscht
leute mit diesem chemie kann man
menschen töten alter
lukas festivalzeitung hoffen dass gleich
das ist schon gedruckt wird
in dieser straße sieht frankfurt
bisschen aus wie new york sind so
hochhäuser überall hochhäuser und die
leute haben ihr wohnzimmer hier direkt
an der straße vor allem auch voll rief
ich müssen lokal richtig reich sein ich
weiß nicht warum aber irgendwie sind wir
jetzt also eine aussichtsplattform und
fahren jetzt so ein tower hoch ist schon
beeindruckend
man kann schon recht weit gucken da der
hafen weiß nicht ob man sieht aber da
ganz hinten ist das stadion von der
eintracht die haben leider gegen bayern
gewonnen im dfb pokal finden also aber
sonst ja schon echt klasse hier hinten
die ganzen häuser und das dinge teilt
die ganz vorne nochmal ein stück höher
arbeiten instagram pushen in meinem blog
eigentlich nur hoch gefahren weil sich
europa nicht gefunden haben
da ist die alte oper deshalb gehen wir
mal ob du bist ganz ein foto von mir und
der alten oper machen
ist ein video statement für das nennt
man regen hermine great time in der
freßgass' etf als echter auch selbst
erscheinen was ich erstmal wie warm ist
gerade wie warm es ist gerade die was
ich dachte das wär alexa geile liegen so
die ganzen ipad geschrieben
das hier ist einfach ca der kleins
mcdonald's bin ich hier gesehen habe ich
vielleicht ein quadratmeter groß ich
gebe nicht mehr werden fragen für die
fahrverbote ein lueg hessen
wir sind wieder in köln angekommen alle
damen und herren und zurück zu hause
angekommen eigentlich dass wir wieder
hier sind glaubt hier zu hause wieder
angekommen werden wir selbstverständlich
erscheint mir den titel bereits
entnehmen könnt machen wir heute einen
fitness-test ich bin alt wie scheiße in
der tat allerdings sicher nicht nur die
motive website nicht bewertet sondern
auch wie sie andere youtuber und
personen des öffentlichen lebens
bewertet und ich würde sagen dass sie
mit diesem test jetzt auch einfach
direkt mal anfangen ja meine sehr
verehrten freudig dazu hier recht
herzlich begrüßt und in beidem aufgabe
zwar ist luca ich habe hier schon die
app offen mit der wir das ganze machen
werden ich wollte das eigentlich meine
website machen diese website existiert
allerdings die wohl irgendwie
runtergenommen oder die betreiber hatten
keine oder keine ahnung was oder die
betreiber haben selbst ein bild von sich
hochgeladen und gesehen dass die echt
hässlich sind gründe sind ja auch
komplett egal auf jeden fall habe ich
mir deine apps runtergeladen die quasi
genau das gleiche kann also ist das
ganze ja auch hier nochmal eingeblendet
irgendwo deswegen würde ich sagen ich
gehe einfach mal auf das kamera symbol
und ich habe auch fünf bilder von
youtube draußen sucht und fünf bilder
von einfach personen des öffentlichen
lebens wie musikern schauspielern
politiker hinzu wir fangen an mit einem
youtuber mit nämlich meinem lieblings
youtuber kontra meine damen und herren
er wird auf 383 17 prozent die noch
fehlen bis zu dem ergebnis was ich
erwartet hätte nächste person die ich
vorbereitet habe meine damen und herren
ist angela merkel sie wird geschätzt ach
du scheiße bewerbung kommissar wallander
werbung rein bund zurück auf die
traurige wahrheit sprechen zu kommen ich
weiß gibt es kein richtiges deutsch war
aber angela merkel ist 10% heißer als
ich
das war so ein richtiger messerstich ins
herz allerdings würde ich sagen wir
lassen uns davon nicht unterkriegen denn
die person die hier hinten schild meine
freundin jule werden wir natürlich auch
austesten freunde juli wird geschätzt
auf 79 prozent hat die schule hier damit
ist sie auf jeden fall anführerin der
liste von unten
er blicke töten könnten die nächste
person die ich vorbereitet habe ist
wieder eine person des öffentlichen
lebens also kein youtuber oder keine
person halt eine person die ich kenne
und zwar ist es patrick dempsey microns
aus utah hat 76 prozent
heißt du bist nicht mehr letzte jude der
ich du hast 79 die nächste person die
straße so zabel selbstverständlich
wieder ein youtuber wir machen das ganze
hier abwechselnd im hat glaube ich jetzt
auch der dümmste unter euch verstanden
spaß freunde ich liebe euch alle auch
engagement in lubumbashi biest youtube l
ist meine damen und herren mal schauen
wie hoch das ganze schnell 84 prozent
bibi ist ein prozent heißer als ich ich
habe euch oben eine umfrage reingepackt
meine damen und herren denkt ihr dass
das stimmt ich bin ein prozent hat sich
oder ist sie vielleicht noch mehr heiß
haut als etwa ist adriano youth hostel
dass hier die nächste person die ich
vorbereitet habe er ca warum kommt hier
nach jeder scheint person so dreckig
lange werbung ich sag's euch freunde ein
paar freunde und ich arbeiten gerade
selber an einer app und ich finde es so
ekelhaft wenn der werbung ist die man
nicht überspringen kann macht wenigstens
eine funktion dass man die werbung weg
kaufen kann
das ist okay das ist vollkommen in
ordnung dadurch finanziert sich die mit
der durch finanzieren sich die app
entwickler und ihre entwicklungen und
die produktion der app aber werbung und
man kann ihn nicht mal wegkaufen bist
echt gemein 79% jule du bist genauso
heiß wie postbranche kep levels ist der
nächste er hat 89 woher ich glaube diese
app ist einfach nur ein stinknormales
ratespielen dir wieder eine person des
öffentlichen lebens nämlich trick und
track and rescue machen wir einfach
wieder eine werbung hier rein hatten war
ja doch nicht genug drake hatte gerade
84 prozent also genauso viel wie bibi
und ein prozent mehr als ich meine damen
und herren die beste person ist
tatsächlich und das muss man leider so
sagen angela merkel ist noch allerdings
meine damen und herren eventuell kann
die nächste person die nächste youtuber
rinnen das ganze für sich
entscheidend ist wird niemand geringeres
als katja grafweg meine damen und herren
wir haben wieder eine werbung
wusstet ihr dass sie wirklich katja
glaser vize ausgesprochen wird also
eigentlich heißt sie kathrin aber katja
es irgendwie ihr künstlername allerdings
würde ich sagen wir entweder das ganze
mit einer person die denke ich jeder
kennen sollte und zwar günther jauch ich
weiß nicht wie ich auf den gekommen aber
er hat 84 prozent also auch günther
jauch es besser aussehen als ich also
wir können festhalten hat ja sie besser
aus als ich angela merkel sieht besser
aus als ich günther jauch sieht besser
aus als ich und ich bin einfach ein
hässlicher spaß und deswegen gehen wir
jetzt erst mal was essen das denn er
beschlossen weil ich hab mal wieder
vergessen zu filmen bevor wir es haben
dass sie haben
danke für ein korb dass sie war auf
jeden fall meine essen ich hatte so
panel mit war nicht so gut
muss ja ich dazu die köche kölner 3par
neuerdings sondern ruft verbauen man
kann hier so komplett über köln da
gucken einmischen
sonnenuntergang getränken eine
kleinigkeit als jahren hier bin ich als
juroren getrennt denn man lernt ja
armes ufo reviews und ihr ausgezogen wir
sind wieder zu hause in der casa der
luca angekommen die dummheit sich das
ändern
auf jeden fall meine damen und herren
kamen heute noch eine lieferung zu mir
nach köln an uns verteidigt dafür
einfach mal hier zum gefrierfach gehen
und ihr seht schon dass dort einige
spitzen am start sind wie der ein oder
andere unter euch wer schon weiß klaren
wir dass wir dieses jahr noch eine
zweite luca pizza herausbringen werden
und deswegen hätte ich gerade unzählige
verschiedene pizza sorten die es auch
teilweise sogar gar nicht im
tiefkühlregal verkaufen gibt und
deswegen sind wir hier alle in diesem
[Musik]
jahr die sind auf jeden fall hier alle
in diesem gefrierfach jetzt drin und wir
testen jetzt mal wieder eine neue von
dem du hast jetzt gefährlich seine
klappe man weiß noch nicht so ganz das
war werden wir noch mal die geheimformel
bei denken müssen
ich glaube der blog ist auch vorbei
[Musik]